Speaking about the world being completely. Uh, Alex Jones turned on Q Anon.
I know almost.
Tough, Matt. They had a rough marriage, they fought it.
They fought it out for years. Uh,
and eventually we just knew someone was going to leave.
Someone tried to leave him a few months ago. Oh,
so what's his name and else's house. The car wasn't in the driveway. Um,
yeah. Well, the thing about,
and that makes it a lot of fun is it's kind of a make it up as you go along.
I've I'm a drug addict, right? So often my lives aren't planned.
They're in the moment, a lot of what I do on the podcast a lot, you know,
it's all in the moment.
I'll have an idea of what I want to talk about and I rant and I go, yeah.
And I've been like stoned and I show up at home and my parents were like,
what's going on? There was $50 on the mantle now it's not there. And I'm like,
well, and I got to make something up on the spot, right? I've been, you know,
are you drinking again? No, I'm not.
And then you had to have a while you were gone for two days,
no one knows where you are and somebody said you left your car. Well, I was,
well, this is, I was at a sales conference and I left my car. I flew to Phoenix.
Like I understand what that is.
Q Anon is an ever-evolving conspiracy theory where the events are happening, uh,
in the past and the present and in the future, it's kind of hilarious.
Every conspiracy theory was at Kennedy, something like that,
that there's a lot of truth in that or all truth. But at the end of the day,
it's like, you're looking back from 30,000 feet,
analyzing little things that have already happened. Cunanan's like,
so I think Alex is kind of like,
I'm a little tired of the constant evolving nature of that conspiracy
theory. So he's.
Not a fan of like the jazz that is Q on.
So they're not because they're improvising.
Constantly. Alex is like, Hey man, I was on board a little bit.
But at the end of the day,
it's gotten a little annoying because it can turn on you.
Eventually you become part of the conspiracy, right?
Alex is controlled opposition. That's what they'll say. Then surely you could,
because Q Anon is just eats things. So it's a conspiracy that just eats things.
The minute you start to say, Hey man, maybe that's not it.
It just eats you and go, well, you're in on it. Right. Everyone's in on it.
Everyone's just satanic pedophile, everybody, everyone, that questions, it is,
uh, eating children. And you go, wait a minute. That seems illogical.
And but now there's not enough children now. There's not enough.
And I think QA is over now, unfortunately, uh, um, because for these people,
but I think fortunately for them, they're going to have to find a new hobby,
but I think it's over now because even the best Q and on people now are starting
to go, Hey man, this might not be going down the way we thought. Yeah.
But they've literally gone as far as to saying that,
like Biden and Trump's switched faces.
Trump's actually still the president except Biden.
You have to be a real moron. Now.
You gotta be real stupid. Now it's at the end. Like when it was cool,
like when the FTC stuff happened, Q Anon was like, it was party at cue.
And then when the hunter bite laptop stuff started to happen,
they were like dancing, like it's time.
And then Biden wins and they're like, wait,
whoa. And it's just like, it's the day after the Q Anon.
If you ever went to a party in high school or college Q1 on right now is the day
after the party. You wake up, it's, it's 12 noon.
The sun is hitting you in the face. You're hung over.
And there's a statue of disgusting beer and cigarettes all over the house.
You're like, what the happened here? I gotta get outta here. I get a bacon, egg,
and cheese. That's what Q1 on is. They got to sober up, get out of that house,
get a bacon, egg, and cheese and go, man, we were whacked.
We were high dude. I thought Nancy Pelosi was eating children for four years.
And the Donald Trump was going to put her in Guantanamo bay. Wow.
That was because it's interesting that people had to do that after the sixties.
They were like, yeah, I just did a bunch of acid.
And I lived in a ranch in Malibu and everyone I ever saw. And they're like,
I thought that was the way the world was going to go.
And I followed some shaman guy,
some guru who just wanted to me and 10 other people that were living there. And,
uh, we did that for three years.
Apparently we never created the utopia we thought we were going to have.
And now I'm back working here, you know,
at Allstate insurance and we have great policies and we'd love you to come into
the office and we can break them down for you in all ends folks, all the law,
all the ends, but it's fun. They had so much fun.
Q Anon was hard to get mad at because they weren't. This was all they had.
Yeah.
They were quite good at it. And then we're good.
And, and, and, and, and, and it was a lot of desperate people,
but there are also rich idiots. There's also like dumb rich people.
And those are like the saddest people in queue, because it's like, they should,
they have the resources to do other things. Yeah. But they just love queue.
They're like, I'm just into this. And I'm like, you're rich,
go do something.
How incurious are you go to the Amazon go birdwatching? I don't know.
But there, you know, so playing golf, it's sad, but they're like done now.
I mean, they're there. Oh, it's over.
I'll see. You think this is the, uh.
I think everything's ending.
My whole thing is that Trump's out Q1 over quarantine is going to end.
Everything's going to go back to something that's more recognizable.
I think that Matt.
Are you optimistic about the 20, 21? I.
Agree in certain aspects, I have optimism. And then I have,
I have short-term optimism and long-term pessimism. Okay.
Meaning that I think in the short-term things can get better.
I think long-term because there's so many forces that are out of our control
that are evolving in ways. I barely understand that are carving up society.
It's going to be very tough longterm to be completely optimistic. Like, Hey,
it's going to be great. It's going to be good forever. But short term, I think,
yeah, there's quarantine will end. Things will get better.
The economy will get a little better. Uh,
the constant Trump craziness will die down a little bit. Um, that's my hope.
And people can go back to focusing on things that matter, which is, you know,
the things that are near you and close.
Yeah. The humans around you, humans around.
You, not Nancy Pelosi. I have my, I have uncles that talk about Nancy plum.
I'm like, you've never met her. Yeah. We'll never meet her shut off. Yeah.
And I have a belief that this kind of local love and
kindness that you naturally can have for human beings that you actually know can
be expanded at scale through the social networks that we
use, that we build out. Twitter is currently failing at that miserably.
That would be great, but that's, if we were.
Able to increase the love.
Through the social networks, that would be great. It feels very hard to,
it's a worthy challenge.